et c'est dans ce contexte que les
ministres ont fait leur entrée hier et
déjà plusieurs annonces rentrée scolaire
reporté au 13 septembre dans les
antilles en raison de la situation
sanitaire la fin du fameux quoi qu'il en
coûte annoncée hier par bruno le maire
le ministre de l'économie katia
technique
le ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
annonce un changement de cap à une
réunion du meedat filière le fameux quoi
qu'il en coûte c'est fini cela marque la
fin des aides pour l'ensemble des
secteurs économiques le ministre
s'appuie sur l'embellie de l'économie
française une hausse de la consommation
une croissance estimée à 6% pour 2021
alors en quoi consistaient les aides de
l'état pour les entreprises durant la
pandémie il s'agissait de l'activité
partielle du fonds de solidarité des
prêts garantis par l'état des reports de
cotisations sociales et fiscales 206
milliards d'euros ont ainsi été
mobilisés par l'état entre le début de
la pandémie fin mars 2021 qui ont
soutenu 3,6 millions d'entreprises cela
représente 9% du pib français avec une
rallonge de 7 milliards pour l'été mais
le robinet se ferme que l'économie soit
libre qu'elle crée des emplois et de la
richesse sans le soutien de l'état a
exhorté bruno le maire d'ailleurs
rejoint par geoffroy roux de bézieux le
président du medef qui a clamé nous ne
sommes pas des entrepreneurs pour vivre
des aides de l'état mais car il ya un
mais il n'y a pas eu un coup de baguette
magique de très nombreuses entreprises
auront encore besoin de soutien
d'ailleurs un rapport de juillet du
comité de suivi des mesures d'urgence
avait recommandé de ne pas arrêter
toutes les aides d'un coup car elles ont
permis d'éviter une explosion du chômage
de très nombreuses faillites alors le
gouvernement continuera à aider le
secteur de la culture de la restauration
du tourisme du voyage de l'hôtellerie
nous sommes passés au sur mesure nous
continuerons à soutenir ceux qui en ont
besoin a affirmé bruno le maire il a
promis d'aider ceux qui ont perdu de
l'argent durant la crise sanitaire bien
sûr mais ceux aussi qui rue tue un
manque à gagner à cause du passé ni
terre ou des réglementations sanitaires
mais il faut songer aussi aux activités
perturbée par les changements de mode de
consommation qui diffère selon les
périodes de restriction ou liberté et
aux commerces qui ont dû dépenser pour
se restructurer et ont dû revenir à la
normale dans les mois d'été alors que
leurs clients habituels étaient en
vacances mais pas sûr que les services
de bercy face dans la dentelle